okay thank you very much for the
invitation I will not be talking about
communities action although I I could
talked about that but I will not talk
about what something entirely different
right okay so let's just get started the
type of problem will be thinking about
now usually these type of statistical
problems then usually known as property
testing our estimation in the CCS theory
the community and the problem is of the
following form I have samples drawn from
some discrete distributions and I want
to learn certain properties of the
distribution either through making the
test or some confidence interval
statement or make a estimate yes okay so
the the only example I will mentioned
today well maybe the major example is
estimate the unseen so this is usually
known as called this problem and what it
really does is to estimate the
cardinality of the support of the
distribution so and that is away so that
is the number of nonzero masses in a
given distribution and I want to know
this quantities integer through repeated
draws from this distribution and one
example is for this guy you have 590
masses yes and apparently this is
exactly equivalent to estimating number
of observe the singles because I can
whatever I have sore I've seen so far
plus those I have never been able to see
it is exactly the total population size
right okay okay so review some classical
result so this is probably the oldest
problem in statistics I mean if you
think about it you don't need to know
gaussians probably the Egyptians of
sorry but there's no paper but the one
of the earliest examples well i think is
one of the favor examples of how long is
the paper a feature at all ok so feature
plus 2 experimentalist so they want some
expedition to some island and they were
there for two years trapping the bat
flies and they want to know how many are
there so I have all these things I
observed but there must be more right so
that you cannot resist attempt to say
there may be more so you need to guess
those things you haven't seen and also
in addition to study of animals in the
study of language and the study of coins
one of the iconic example is how many
words the Shakespeare know I did
Shakespeare know if I give you all the
the place you have written you want to
guess what is his vocabulary size
including those words he ever got the
chance to use right so it's a nice thing
and I will not discuss probability
estimation that is to estimate what's
the chance that the next symbol is new
so that's go touring and I don't need a
long sequence of work alone these type
of problems their connections but I will
not discuss that okay so let's go to
mathematics so the samples I already
know Dwight X 1 to X and they are you
know simplest idks are drawn from six
distribution P and I want to come up
with some estimate which is measurable
to my data too close to the true support
size either in probably 80 or
expectation I want to do this with the
minimum sample size as possible you know
the words I want to find a statistical
limit of the of this problem and also I
want to have a fast procedure that
achieves it right so this is hoping for
and and if you think about it of course
now you need to assume something about
distribution you have to assume
something about because I can put a tiny
mass somewhere I can put a lot of tiny
match somewhere you will never be able
to see it right so youryour stuffer he
lost so you need to assume something
about non zero mass that has to be
bigger and something this is exactly the
same as in estimating that the support
of a sparse vectoring noise you need to
assume the non-zeros exceeds the the
root log P right the fluctuation of the
noise it's the same idea right so let's
the cut the conventional assumption is
assume distributions the minimum mass is
at least 1 over K let's call all these
distributions d of K and implicitly the
alphabet size right this kiss is also at
most K but I want to know the support
right number of non-zeros and let me
just formally define sample complexity
of this problem as let me just read it
is the minimum sample size for which you
can come up with estimate to get within
the truth plus minus epsilon times K
with probability at least one half so
this is mayra epsilon K I just put
something here because you will see that
naturally there because these these
support size is self typically will be
large half of K oh I don't know k
divided by root K so the error will be
also proportional okay but this is just
the repolarization and I want to this to
hold for any such distributions and two
very quick remarks the I just put one
half here just for convenient if I want
to upgrade my confidence from one half
to lesson 1 minus 1 over 10 to the minus
5 I only need to do the following the
classical procedures I need to over
sample log 1 over Delta and what I need
to do is to cut the samples and apply
the same procedure and take the medium
and use hosting that's it exponential
concentration so it's it's very simple
so let's just focus on this just for
simplicity another trivial case is if I
want exactly zero error right I want
with high probability my estimate is
going to be exactly equal to that and
you will see very simple this is exactly
the coupon collector problem you need
que lo que right sleeve for this to
happen but if I can tolerate a little
bit there right maybe I can do better
and indeed what would would anyone do
what would be the Egyptians approach
right so now we'll just take whatever
I've seen so far so what I see is what I
estimate this is what what people don't
you can also interpret it as a plug-in
right so i take the empirical
distribution i compute its support size
and declare that as my estimate and this
is obviously underestimate and is
usually grossly underestimate the truth
in the interesting sub-linear sampling
regime where you do not have a lot of
samples right
you could have a huge alphabet okay so
this is not going to cut it but the
rationale behind the scene estimator is
I'm trying to estimate distribution
itself then plug it plug it in right so
it's it's actually not a good idea to to
estimate it yourself because this is a
humongous high dimensional object for
which probably you need linear right
okay samples and you can do no better
than empirical distribution but in this
type of situation is unique about one
number so it's not entirely unthinkable
that you can do better little of K but I
can also give you examples where even if
you want to estimate one function you
need exactly same number of samples but
in this case maybe you can do something
here that is it's not so clear okay so
let's let's go a little bit deeper into
this so the sufficient statistic for
this problem is obviously first thing
you can think is the histogram number of
currencies of the J symbol right disease
obvious but then in fact because the
quantity you want to estimate is
permutation variant so the histogram of
the histogram is in fact also sufficient
you can further summarize histogram by
its own histogram so this is what
usually people call fingerprints of
profiles that's the number of symbols
that exactly occurred once twice three
times worse if I give you this you can
do whatever you can as if you have the
raw data right so this is what's
efficiency means in this case and h0 is
precisely number of unobserved guys is
not compute okay so what do people do
beyond the naive approach well so a lot
of popular approaches falls under the
category of linear estimators veneering
what linear in the fingerprints one way
to ask to understand what we're doing
here is I have some function which
applied to every histogram and I just
add it up equivalently I can write it as
a linear combination of the finger
just different a way to to do the
bookkeeping and the plugin the number of
things is precisely these things I think
once twice three times forces and it's a
linear combination with all one
coefficient is what was what what is
usually better it's some other things
now you see this is crazy so what we're
doing now is I if I see something once I
had something if I seeing something
twice i subtract something and i add
more and i subtract more and actually
works very well and there's a lot of
interpretations of this procedure and
also there is another one I think I from
since though is that the tribute to
feature is some bajan estimators from
some gamma priors and it also of this
one but they want to kill the
observations by adding some panoramio
tails right so it grows and then dies
okay so it's all ugly sorry hmm here
second second one I mean you can you can
take to equal to ten to run it cuz on
before we get minus two thousand or
something but I don't think there is
anything they proved here all these are
let's say what have very strong prove or
result okay so so what do we know
probably well we can prove very easily
that if you just estimate by what you
saw and then the sample complexity is at
most K times log 1 over epsilon so this
is not going to be sub linear in the
inkay but the dependence on the error is
long one hour episode is exponential
concentration it's not so bad okay it's
not so good okay so then there is a
sequence of result which showed that sub
linear is possible so a poor valiant and
Greg variant in the audience and the
another group of people so essentially
what they showed is that using linear
programming which is roughly the same
procedure in ephraim fees that but they
did exact reverse analysis that you can
do with sub linear so it's k / okay so
it's the extra little of k now but
dependents on epsilon is 1 over epsilon
square right so and there's also a lower
bound but there is no explicit
dependence on only error but you know
the k / okay is the correct scaling so
what i will show you is that actually
you can get the best of the both roughly
speaking so you can get sub linear cable
okay and independence instead of 1 over
epsilon square which is polynomial you
get put in logarithmic so it's log
square of 1 over epsilon so if you think
about it this is actually sub
exponential concentrations the tail is
like e to the minus square root of
something and then indeed if you if you
refuse to look at sample complexity look
at minimax risk and you can prove
essentially that the term that give you
square root of log is exponential square
root of this so so i will show you
essentially the positive result for
these laws and negative result for fall
food for the previous 01 loss but
anyways yes so that's what while doing a
remainder of the talk
right so so what's a principled way to
design estimator which turns out to be
linear and with good provo optimality
and also very natural lower bound to
prove impossibility result through a
duality argument okay so a little bit of
background I will be very quick here so
you can define a best program
approximation for some function on given
finite interval as simply the best
proxima turn into this function under
mvt norm right so and you know by the
denseness of polynomials you can
proximate a continuous function very
well if you have very large degree in
the in the in the polynomial and how
fast usually depend on how smooth the
function is and also you can view it
view the best error as finite
dimensional convex programming right the
lv norm is Canucks and also infinite
dimensional linear programming this is
this view is important why okay so this
is just some examples right I want to
look at a duo of this problem do this
problem is precisely the following aiko
it more than matching so the idea is
you're doing the following optimization
problem you to pick two random variables
so that their moment match one two three
four up to some L but their expectation
under these given function differs as
much as possible right so there is some
of course some tension between the
objective and you're constrained because
if F is very small if you just do the
Taylor expansion the first L term is
going to be annihilated so this is not
going to be very big and you have to
pick it very carefully and of course the
observation now is not over unendurable
over its law but i will just write in
this style of rotations so and this
problem is over probability measures but
you only have finite number of
constraint so if we attach each deal
variable to this and compute is its do
program and you will see that's
precisely the best linear best polio
approximation and the role of the dual
variable plays the coefficient of the
polynomials
so and you can show there is no duality
gap there are many methods to do this
and usually the random variable look at
this but it's not important okay so let
me say something about the opportunity
jure first this implication you can do
is to personalize your sampling model so
instead of dro fixed and samples let me
draw parcel number of samples with me n
and then draw samples then what the
benefits of this is that a it makes the
histograms independent now so it's
independent no identical puzzle random
variables and it only affect all these
streets ago limits that you're looking
for by constant factors that is a good
plus and the main problem with the usual
naive approach is his huge bias so let's
look at if we can do unbiased estimators
of course not because anything that you
can estimate without any bias is either
polynomials if without put some sampling
Oh analytic functions you have so these
these garbage is is not even continuous
of course there is no way to to estimate
it without any bias so but the idea is
that maybe we can approximate it by some
this is contiguous because you made the
assumption that all of the nonzero is a
more than 110 right but there's might as
well make a little slope of 1 over K yes
for example that's you see yes so you
will see that the butt but you can you
cannot make it you cannot make it never
make it analytic right because you have
if you can there's a constant function
if you can't if you coincide on any open
interval right are you gonna be your
whole thing is flat ok so there's yeah
so even if you do that there's no way
12-0 bias but maybe you can approximate
it by something you can made unbiased
Lee and then do that right but this is
roughly the idea but to execute this
plan we can do it a little bit
differently ok so so we're going to
design some guinea estimators so I have
some intuition of how to pick these
coefficient mayan division is the
following if I haven't seen anything I
shouldn't I should shut up right i
should i shouldn't say it's actually i
should add to so that's stupid if it has
appeared
let's say a million times in 2 million
samples what do I know I know that guy
is in the alphabet and I know the mass
it's probably all half and I shouldn't
say anything else it's only for those
guys would peer at once or twice that I
probably that I had I have the inclusion
that there are probably small masses
there who didn't get to show up but I
need to correct for that right so that's
so if I you know pick 0 here and 0 ones
over there my I'm left over with picking
these coefficients in the middle right
so that's the that's the meat so how do
I do it right well actually I didn't do
anything if if you just write out the
bias what you can notice here this is
this term is precisely polynomial of
degree L this is where a cut so so I
made a bunch of details but as you can
see this function here is some small
exponential times the polynomial of
degree l and then now the thing that you
need to do is to pick a polynomial of
degree L at passes through minus 1 and
oscillate deviate from zero a little bit
right so you want to optimize this
scheme and it turns out the solution
exactly chebyshev polynomial so the
shape the picture for this is that's
Ramon sad this is my step function the
thing that and I know here is forbidden
right there is no mass here between 0
and 100 ok but I want to design some guy
and passes through here and and between
in this gray region I suffer nothing
because there is no mass but here i want
to just operate in a little bit and this
is given a budget on a degree and this
is exactly given by chebyshev polynomial
now i can find my procedure which is
simply looking at a shifted version of
chebyshev polynomial and computers
coefficient and that's it and sure and
here you see I don't even need to split
the samples so I can do it that's
because usual approach is to see ok
where should i plug in for big mass i
plug in for small mass i do some some of
this stuff here i just do it did it in
one shot so
there is no need to do these things and
also it's of course it's faster than
linear programming and it's not
surprising and okay so where does the
square root out fix influential comes
comes from the just a small expansion of
the cosine and the variance is actually
a small return and if you look at the
coefficient that computed from the
chebyshev polynomial it's very similar
to f1 sister it start to grow and then
start and then died so but I have I have
no explanation of why you need to have
you know alternating signs and also
these fluctuations I have no intuition
from first principles yes in hindsight
is optimal but why does it help it's
very mysterious to me okay so I want to
say a little bit about the impossibility
result all right let me just jump to the
main idea so the idea is to is to pick
two random distributions and and draw a
realizations from the distribution so I
have distribution over distributions and
then draw the samples for example
suffusion statistics and a goal is to
confuse this decision right so if they
have very different support size but
from a data I can now tell which
ensemble they are from then I'm screwed
so this is the main idea but it's
difficult to implement this plan is
because if you think about the random
distribution of course these entries are
coupled because they normalize yes so so
this is some personal have very high
dimensional for some mixtures it's not
very easy to compute distance but the
key construction is the following
suppose I have some random variable ways
you need me I can populate a
distribution with its identical copies
of course now I will not get exact
distributions right so I this guy will
not be supported on the probability
simplex but it will just be a little bit
fuzzy around the promising parts because
of law of large numbers and I can do the
same thing for the other guy and and the
the benefits of this brooch is that aha
now I can use some very you know simple
argument to show that yes I can take
this essentially as my probably
distribution their clothes but they are
not but it's fine but
now the sports eyes concentrates why
because how many non zeros are in this
distribution just the K times the
probability of nonzero months I put that
here same for that so I need to separate
this and the sufficient statistics not
become ID so this is this is the
benefits then for product distributions
I only need to treat them as one
dimensions and prove that marginals are
closed so this is essentially reduce the
problem from k dimensions to 1
dimensions and the good sufficient
condition to ensure they are closed is
that they have the same moments for a
lot of things ok so the program I'm
going to solve now is the following so I
have this recipe to generate to lower
bound right so I want to pick two random
variables so think about this as a
matter of distributions you generate
distribution like this and when i
whenever the constraint are satisfied
that assurance is going to be confused
right and this is the loss you suffer so
I want to maximize the suffering subject
to this constraint and this problem
there is a it's dangerously close to
moment mashing but there is something
different first this is not a very
smooth function and second I need some
hard constraint on the on the only me
but fortunately in this problem you can
solve it exactly you can do some change
of measures and you can find out it's
actually exact the proximate of 10 racks
function for which the solution is also
some cheap shipping these guys and you
have the same score route on
Exponential's that's why I have the
exact I should mention that the main
inspiration of this the idea of looking
at the polynomials and moments are
inspired by earlier work of in Gaussian
models in particular number of key and
the pony car here the authors in these
papers so what here there is something
will be different with probabilities and
also the compared to the previous
breakthrough result in valiant valiant
and the main difficulty there at least
in the lower bound is deal with large is
very high-dimensional distributions but
you're essentially you have a small
argument just make it reduce to one
dimension so this is like summarization
right so experiments yeah okay I'll
mention a little bit about Shakespeare I
just stopped here so this is being a
programming and this is you know this
chebyshev with degree 10 and they
roughly behave something like the same
yes this is a give you some passage of
hamlet and you guess how many words are
there ok i just want to say one last
thing before there is a very closely
related problem which is like a
subproblem of this it's called species
problem and one way to for Milady's have
a urn of cables of some color all right
same color disc and you want to ask me
how many colors are there in the ball by
repeated drawers so these are special
case because the distributions are mass
is a proportion of 1 over K 300 1 over K
to allocate right of course you can
implement whatever what have did with
Shiva chef right so it's going to work
but the question is can you do better
the answer is actually yes because why
because recall this picture this is what
we're doing we're approximately step
function and we know there's no mass
here there is one mass probably here and
the other things are here right if you
in the species problem actually you know
the mass is a discrete so there is no
mass actually in between you only have 1
over K 2 or ok so you can design some
interpolating polynomials and pass
through all these points and you'll have
exactly zero bias so instead of uniform
protection over all these masses you can
take advantage of this structure and do
better in this case you kill the square
root of K in some regime ok so not okay
so entropy I think Gentile we'll talk
about this you have similar result but
here I have to do some sample splitting
and approximately different function
right so ok I want to stop here and just
say that in the general case what you
can say is the century it's governed by
this following
converse for women where you have
essentially a logarithmic number of
constraint and you solve it you can say
a lot about the statistical limit and
the thing I want to the main message I
want to say is the primal program of
this give you impossibility result give
you Congress the deal of these give you
a procedure that you can you can extract
from the deal so but I do not have time
to go into this okay I'll just stop here
there are two preprints and this one
will appear I don't know when but
depending on the mood of archive stop
here thank you we have time for one
question yeah for chip chip for an
ambiance and what's that degree where do
you need to thank you ah first of all I
never truncate the degree is log is is
long in the in the sample size i say i
find the restriction on DK so that all
of the non zero probability entries are
more than one of a capability mystic
innocent if you look for example on
Hamlet there's probably like one very
difficult word that appears somewhere in
Hamlet's that just appears once right
right so you know you could say okay I
don't want to estimate exactly the
support i want to estimate just say yes
the number of points that make up words
in the ball to the distribution or you
know i won't ask you can do that yeah
you can do that you can essentially say
something about the other statistics
about the lucky okay doesn't have to
make it cut off with one over K I only
care about things that I probably mean
one of okay but to assume that there's
nothing actually that is actually known
that that it actually is not solvable i
can give you examples where is i thought
you know i only care about the some of
the big guys right the heavy hitters but
know that problem is actually 0 define i
can show you that is
regarding the metric you're measuring
that I let one is is looking at a number
of non-zeros range there is a
probability of em being sort of showing
up as a part of the distribution oh yeah
so that's more yeah what alone the
probability of the UH things right so
the four so that's a random quantity so
it depends on your sample you can ask me
is mean by this type of procedures but
yeah in general I don't you still that's
reading this abortion the error i made
sure if it's a alphabetic excellent are
not silly I'll get a penalty which is
abortion at the probability distribution
okay so small masses will cause less lip
gloss my decision yeah okay I never saw
ya factory okay